Democrats in Congress are putting new
pressure on President Trump and his
Attorney General to reveal information
they are holding back
Robert Muller's investigators reportedly
believe that William Barr left out
important details in his summary of the
special counsels report on Russian
interference the 2016 election now
that's according to reports in The New
York Times and The Washington Post the
House Judiciary Committee has now
authorized subpoenas for molars report
in full with no redactions and the house
and Ways and Means chairman spent a
formal request to the IRS yesterday to
inspect mr. Trump's tax returns
Paula Reid is at the White House with
more on this story Paula there's a lot
to unpack this morning good morning to
you there is quite a bit to unpack gale
and here Democrats are crossing the
president's bright red line by seeking
his personal tax returns and this comes
amid a broader escalation of
investigations into all things Trump
until such time as I'm not under ordered
I would not be inclined to do this there
is no policy that prevents anyone from
releasing their tax returns while under
audit but the president repeated this
false claim when asked about House
Democrats demanding his returns I've
been under ordered for many years
because the the numbers are big and I
guess when you have a name you in a
letter to the IRS House Ways and Means
Committee Chairman Richard Neal relies
on a little-known tax law to support his
request for six years of the president's
tax returns as well as returns from
eight other Trump entities Neil insists
the request is about policy not politics
but not everyone agrees this is not
oversight this is overreach and because
they can't indict and impeach him they
want to embarrass and harass him and
those around him and America sees it for
what it is
meanwhile the House Judiciary Committee
now has a subpoena for the full Muller
report it is imperative that the
committee take possession of these
documents and others without delay
overnight both the New York Times and
The Washington Post reported some in the
special counsels team are unhappy with
attorney general william VAR summary
democrats were quick to seize on those
reports to bolster their claims that bar
should release more why didn't he really
a summary produced by Bob Muller himself
inste instead of trying to shape it
through his own words the reports were
not attributed to special counsel team
members by the president's personal
attorney voodoo Giuliani still blasted
Muller's team over the latest reports it
makes the point that we've been making
for two years despite all of the media
reports about how holy and sanctimonious
the mullet team is they're they're a
bunch of sneaky unethical leakers bar
has promised to release a redacted
version of the report by mid-april the
Democrats say anything short of the full
report will prompt them to issue a
subpoena likely leaving it to a federal
judge to decide how much of this report
is eventually made public Nora waiting
Thank You Paula